ττάπου είχαμε να φτάσουμε σε τν τοαποτέλασμα που βλέπουμε σήμερα που είναι καλύτερο από εκείνο
που εβλέπαμε τότε δεν είναι καλόν έχουμε γκρίση α ακόμα έχουμε εγκρίσι ναδρευτικού κομε δεν
έχουν λειτουργής ι μονάδες ημονάδες καιστερούν αλλά φανταστείται να μην χρησιμοποιοσαμε συντμήμεενες και γρήγορες διαδικασίες
αυτή ήταν όμως ι καταλισμά και είμα στε δελείο από ότην αλήθεια ότι στην κύπρον
είμαστε κάποσεβαίσθητης το θέμα τις λέξεις τις συγκεκριμένες και ήταν αστοχονόντως όπως έγινε η διτλοποίηση
το όλου θέματας αι δεν εφανίζε τον σύνολο έδωσε ένα νένασμα να γίνει κάποιος αλ
όποιος ε διαβαζεν όμως την πρόση να ξεκάθαροντ να που ελέγαμενα αλλά πισή στην κύπρο
το έχουμε να μένουμε στον τίτλο και να η επηγαίνουμε στο ναι ριεχόμεκα όντως έχουμε
τ θαινόμενο πο οποίο ενπαντού είναι μό στην κύπρο ναρά είναι εμείς που πρέα προσθαρμοστούμε
σ το φαινόμενο νόι το θανομετ σεπιότες υπουργικών έγινε για να γίνει για να κάμνουμε
αντιπολίτευση τοσιότες το ξκιότες κυπουργικό ανπάμε ότι ττο συμβούλιο το πρώτο θέμε ένα παρακολουθεία θεμαδό
δευτερο αξονας του είναι να παρεμβαίνει ακριβώ αντιπολύευσδιδια παρεμβαίνει στα θέματα αλλά να παρεμβαίνειμε βάσει
τ τι μας εδώς είνα εντολή το συνέίδρινο του κόμπάως να παρεμβαίνουμε δηλαδή με επικοδομητικήνα
αντιπολίδευ που σημαίνει με απλά λογιά αντιπολίδε συναοποίας το χέβει στη βελτίωση της ζωής του
κόσμο έτσι την αντιλαμβανομε εγώ έτσι την ερμηνεύω αυτό ερμηνεύώ αυτό κάμλο τ υναεπικόδομητική μεχρη
τώρα η αντιπολίτευση που ασκίτοι αντιπολίδευση που αςκείτε είναι επικοδομητική ακριβώς για τον λόγον ότι
η προσπάθεια μας είναι ακριβώς να βελτιωθεί εκείνο το θέμα το οποίο να γύρουμε από
έρα παράδια προσεύτ και το είδατικώ επαραδιγμα που εκάμαμε μετά που η κυβέρνηση ενεργοποιήθηκαν κας